Film Courage: You left Los Angeles and you’re
back in Washington [state].
What was the impetus for this?
Author and Creative Jeff Leisawitz: Moving
to Washington?
Film Courage: Yes.
Jeff Leisawitz: I just needed a new scene.
I need some more green.
I kind of like the rain, I mean I do like
rain.
Film Courage: It’s beautiful up there.
Jeff Leisawitz: Rain down on me.
Film Courage: There you go and you’re a
[The] Who fan.
But at what point?
Because everybody talks about going somewhere
else.
But a lot of people don’t do it.
What was it where you just said “It’s
time.
NFA.
I want to change my course in life.”
Jeff Leisawitz: Well, one of the pieces was
I was young, I was like 24, 25.
So when we’re younger we have more flexibility
I think in our choices and in our lifestyles
and things like that.
On of the things that I try to get across
to my college students that I teach song writing
and recording to college students which like…that’s
a job?
Are you kidding me?
I love it.
But I try to get them to understand the power
and flexibility of their youth because they
don’t really know it because they haven’t
been 15 years older yet.
They haven’t been in the workforce and running
around.
They are just getting out of school or in
school.
So that was a piece of it.
Being young and I knew sort of where I wanted
to go with my life but it just seemed like
a good place.
Film Courage: Another thing that I say a lot
in these interviews but I’m going to say
it again is that when you are 20 or 24 people
give you pats on the back and they give you
“Attagirl!
Attaboy!
You can do it.”
When you are 40, they don’t do that.
And I think that part of it is there is part
of them that wants to do that and they can’t
[mostly from obligations] and it’s all very
real thing in the adult world.
You have certain roles and obligations and
so you don’t get as many Attagirls!
[or Attaboys!].
Jeff Leisawitz: That’s true.
Maybe you can’t drop everything and move
to different city.
But you always can do something and that is
the key, right?
A huge difference is you’ve got to pay the
rent and whatever the deal is.
Okay, I get that, of course.
But if you want to be a screenwriter, spend
a half an hour a day or two hours on a Saturday
or whatever it is.
A little bit and you absolutely can do that.
It’s just about prioritizing, right?
Are you watching TV or are you writing on
your screenplay?
I mean…let’s get real.
Film Courage: Going back to the image in the
beginning of your book [NFA: The No B Guide
For Getting Your Creative Dreams Off The Ground].
Jeff Leisawitz: Are you going to the bar or
are you practicing guitar, right?
There’s a million ways to go, there’s
a million things that you probably don’t
need in your life.
Do you have to play video games for two hours
a day….hhmmm?
Probably not, you know.
You can do something productive with that
if you choose.
Film Courage: What about that being the lonelier
way?
Because going to the bar there are 20 other
people there that can be part of what…and
this isn’t my quote ‘The Ain’t it Awful
Club.’
It’s from author Peter McWilliams, he wrote
a book [You Can't Afford the Luxury of a Negative
Thought - The Life 101 Series].
And he said there is one [The Club] in every
workplace, there’s one in every bar.
And it’s great.
You can commiserate, we know politics is a
hot button right now.
But you go back home and you write that screenplay,
it’s pretty much just you.
It’s lonely.
Jeff Leisawitz: It is lonely.
Life is lonely, right?
But it’s yours to choose.
So if you want to be in that club, go ahead.
But don’t whine to me about it or yourself.
Because we all have power and perhaps it’s
lonely writing by yourself but guess what?
There’s a million writing clubs out there,
writing Meetups and things like that.
So join one of those.
And suddenly you’re all writing by yourself
but at least you’re at the same table.
I mean I’ve done that a million times.
Film Courage: Is that why you write in coffee
shops or maybe you don’t (I’m just assuming).
Jeff Leisawitz: I do sometimes, sometimes
not.
I mean that’s why half the people go to
coffee shops.
In Seattle you will see 40 people in a room,
four or five of them are talking to each other
and everybody else is on the computer doing
something.
Why do they do that?
Because they want to be together even though
they are separate.
And I mean I’m not saying it’s the greatest
thing in the world.
If you’re together, you kind of want to
be together, but it’s something.